es waren sie keinen fahrschein und dann
prügeln sie auch noch in einer bahn
richtung hamburg wurden jetzt 80
jugendliche beim schwarzfahren erwischt
als die polizei dann dazu kam rasteten
sie aus bei den schwarzfahrern soll es
sich um aktivisten einer kurdischen
jugendbewegung handel sie waren in einem
zug aus lüneburg unterwegs alle ohne
fahrschein als sie kontrolliert wurden
sollen sie die zugbegleiterin auf
massive weise verprügelt haben im
bahnhof von bardowick griff dann die
bundespolizei mit mehr als 200 beamten
ein
unterstützt wurden sie dabei durch
weitere einsatzkräfte der landespolizei
viele personen hätten sich unkooperativ
gezeigt so die polizei sie hätten die
beamten geschlagen und getreten
mehrere polizisten hätten leichte
verletzungen erlitten
die aktivisten sollen vor einigen tagen
proteste in hannover und den landkreisen
celle uelzen lüneburg und harburg
organisiert haben
nach übernachtungen in einem camp in
lüneburg seien sie auf dem weg nach
hamburg gewesen als es zu dem
zwischenfall kam
sie erwarte jetzt ein strafverfahren
wegen erschleichung von leistungen und
wegen körperverletzung und widerstand
gegen vollstreckungsbeamte
außerdem habe die überprüfung der
personalien ergeben dass sich mehrere
der reisenden unerlaubt in deutschland
aufhalten
bei den schwarz fahren soll es sich um
aktivisten einer kurdischen
jugendbewegung mir nun zugeschaltet mein
kollege thomas knoop thomas wie sieht
die aktuelle situation aus ja ich bin
hier in hamburg und hinter mir läuft
eine neue demonstration der kurdischen
jugendbewegungen die polizei dachte wir
sind ungefähr rund 100 teilnehmer die
polizei mit starken kräften vor ort weil
derzeit gestern diesen vorfällen in dem
zug von liebold gab
denn dort momentan alles friedlich
gerade die bilder von gestern gesehen wo
die randalierer auf die polizei
losgegangen sind die stimmung
ein star zum anfassen das ganze deutsche
zeit dauern und man weiß nicht genau wie
es weitergeht ist jetzt ein stiegen in
lüneburg ein und hatte keine fahrscheine
dabei alle scharren wurde dann
angegangen
die polizei stoppte den fahrer und die
mir eine sprecherin der polizei kam es
zu angriffen auf polizeibeamte insgesamt
200 beamte zusammengezogen man hat die
versorgung der teilnehmer dann
festgestellt vielen dank thomas knoop in
hamburg dankeschön
wir sind bild und wir liefert dir deine
news auf youtube zum nächsten video
kommst du hier
und vergiss bitte nicht unseren kanal zu
abonnieren